[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: If your app uses
background threads for loading
or processing data-- and pretty
much every app will need those
at some point-- you might have
to take special precautions
to make your UI
test run reliably.
Espresso does most of the
heavy lifting for you,
waiting for life
cycle events to finish
and checking if the UI is idle.
But it can't always know what
the other parts of your app
are doing.
And you might need to write
some additional code to make
synchronization possible.
Let me show you an example.
I'll create a new
project in Android Studio
with the empty
activity template.
Let's do some initial
setup for testing.
I'll add the Android
runner, rules,
and Espresso dependencies
in my Android test scope.
If you're ever unsure what the
newest versions for Espresso
packages are, consult the
documentation or our testing
samples on GitHub, which
we always keep up to date.
I then set up the test
instrumentation runner,
and we're done here.
Onto the main activity class.
The only thing it
does right now is
set a layout for the text view.
Let me open the layout
and change that text
and give the text view an ID.
And on resume, I'm going
to change the text.
And I'll just quickly
extract the string
into a resource
for later re-use.
Let's create a UI test for
the activity using an Android
Studio shortcut.
Add the annotation to use the
Android test runner first.
Then I need to set
up the activity test
rule that will start my activity
and check if the correct text
is displayed.
I run the test, and it passes.
That's because Espresso
waits until the app processes
all life cycle events.
And I'm sending it a text
string on resume, remember?
Let's simulate a more
realistic scenario
where the data takes
some time to load.
AsyncTask is one of the simplest
ways to do background work
and then pass a result
back to the main thread.
So what happens when
I run the test now?
Surprisingly, it passes.
That's because
Espresso also knows
how to synchronize on
the AsyncTask thread
pull out of the box.
And because AsyncTask are also
at the heart of any AsyncTask
loader, including cursor
loaders, they just work.
Of course, there's
lots of other ways
you can schedule
background work.
It can be connecting to a remote
API, using a custom thread
pull, or through
handler messaging.
You can see I'm
changing the code
to use a separate
thread, which sleeps
for 5 seconds to
simulate background work,
then posts the change
back to the main thread.
When I run the test,
it fails immediately.
As soon as on resume returns
and the activity is idle,
Espresso is trying to validate
the message on the text view
and it fails
because the runnable
hasn't had a chance to run yet.
That's when you have
to use idling resources
to tell Espresso when your
app is busy processing.
I'll use an implementation
of an idling resource
that we provide
with Espresso called
counting idling resource.
It's very simple to
use, and it basically
lets you increment a counter
for every resource that is busy
when you're waiting
for something to finish
loading and decrement
it when it's done.
Espresso will
automatically run whenever
the counter is at zero.
I'll give it a name, data
load, used mostly for logging.
But it has to be unique among
registered idling resources.
Now, increment before
scheduling my runnable
and decrement when it's done.
The only thing left is
to register the resource
with Espresso.
In the test class,
I'll add a setup method
to grab the idling resource
instance from the activity.
And it's done.
Run test.
After 5 seconds, the
counter gets decremented
and the test passes.
To sum up, if your tests are
flaky or outright failing
because of background threads
and asynchronous events,
use idling resource
to tell Espresso when
to pause and resume its work.
That's all for this episode.
Happy testing.
[MUSIC PLAYING]